Elena ce sont des chiffres communiqués
par l'ONU ce matin un million
d'ukrainien ont déjà fui le pays ont
déjà franchi les frontières on est au
bord d'une crise humanitaire dramatique
oui je pense que d'abord les Ukrainiens
savent quelle est la machine qui est en
marche pour les attaquer ils ont les
enquêtes les images de Rosny on parle de
Kiev donc effectivement les gens ont
peur ils ont été plongés dans cette
guerre donc les gens fuient d'abord les
combats je pense aussi que les gens ont
peur de l'instauration du régime de
Vladimir Poutine hormis le fait que ils
sont en train d'essayer de sauver leur
vie il y a aussi cette peur sans doute
de voir arriver ce régime de voir
arriver tout ce qui va aller avec en
terme de persécution des opposants de ce
qui était anti de ce qui était procréné
de ce qui était patriote de ce qui
soutenait la résistance de l'Ukraine
face à face
c'est c'est la plus grande majorité de
c'est la plus grande partie de l'Ukraine
occidentale depuis que ce conflit a lieu
en 2014 c'est-à-dire que les Ukrainiens
à la base sont extrêmement PA mais avec
avec ce qu'ils ont considéré toujours
comme une agression à une occupation de
l'Est de leur pays par la Russie
effectivement les le sentiment anti-rhus
était très fort le sentiment patriote
est de résistance à cette agression
était très très fort et donc ça fait des
années que les
Ukrainiens en parle ouvertement et
cetera que ce qu'il s'agit des
journalistes des officiels des gens tout
simplement donc effectivement là ils
savent que et Vladimir Poutine a dit
d'ailleurs qu'il y aurait des procès
qu'il y aurait des règlements de compte
il a dit ouvertement donc ça je pense
que ça fait tout au moins un peu aux
gens que juste les combats et le fait de
sauver leur vie merci